welcome everyone this is part one in our
series on grounded language
understanding i'm just going to give an
overview with grounding i feel like
we're really getting at the heart of
what makes nlu so special for nlp but
and also for artificial intelligence
more broadly so this is exciting let's
dive in now grounding is a very large
topic and so to ground it so to speak
we're going to be focused on a
particular task which is color reference
in context i'll be saying much more
about that later on this notebook colors
overview
provides an overview of the data set
and that data set is the center piece
for the homework and associated bank off
the core reading is the paper that
introduced that data set monroe at all
2017 and i think that paper is
noteworthy also for introducing some
interesting modeling ideas that are
worthy of further exploration possibly
in final projects
and i also just want to recommend a
whole bunch of auxiliary readings not
required but exciting extensions that
you might make i think grounding is a
wonderful chance to do interdisciplinary
work you can connect to nlp connect nlp
with
robotics and computer vision and human
language acquisition and probably lots
of other topics so i'm going to be
pushing papers and data sets throughout
this series of screencasts in hopes that
you can pick up those ideas and run with
them for your own projects
now to start i thought we could just
reflect a little bit on
the heart of this which is why grounding
is so important uh and why natural
language understanding is so hard and
sort of to kick that off uh i've taken a
slide idea from andrew mccallum and just
andrew just asks us to reflect a little
bit on the 1967 stanley kubrick movie
2001 a space odyssey
in that movie the spaceship's computer
which is called hal can do three things
that are noteworthy it can display
computer graphics it can play chess and
it can conduct natural open domain
conversations with humans so this is a
chance to ask
how well did the filmmakers do it
predicting what computers would be
capable of in the actual year 2001 which
is of course ancient history for us at
this point
so let's start with the graphics on the
left you have some of gra of the
graphics that hal is able to display in
the movie and you can see that they are
extremely primitive
the filmmakers seem to have wildly
underestimated just how much progress
would happen in computer graphics by
1993 which is much earlier than 2001 of
course we had the movie jurassic park
which had these incredible graphics for
life like moving dinosaurs
so let's say that this is a kind of
failure to imagine the future
for chess it seems like they've got the
prediction just about right so in the
movie hal is an excellent chess player
and just a few years before the actual
2001 in 1997 deep blue uh was the first
super computer to beat world champion
chess players
what about dialogue and natural language
use so on the left here you have a
sample dialogue from the movie
dave bowman is the human he says open
the pod bay doris hal and hal replies
i'm sorry dave i'm afraid i can't do
that
what are you talking about hal and how
it replies i know that you and frank
were planning to disconnect me and i'm
afraid that's something i cannot allow
to happen
very interesting not only is it fluent
english of course but it's also
displaying really rich reasoning about
plans and goals and it's fully grounded
in what's happening in the ship
just incredibly realistic
to give the filmmakers even a fighting
chance here let's move forward to the
year 2014 which is about when siri hit
the market
and we talked about siri earlier here
you can see siri doing some a much more
mundane version of what we just saw hal
doing which is kind of proactively
recognizing plans and goals and helping
a human user solve a problem using
fluent english in this case it's just
about where to buy food um but the
vision is very similar
what's at what was life actually like in
2014 or for that matter in the present
day well i also showed you this dialogue
from stephen colbert from his show the
pretense is that he has been playing
with his phone all day and therefore has
failed to produce material for the show
the cameras are on him and he's
desperate he asks siri for help and you
can see here that siri does not have a
deep understanding of what he's trying
to achieve i've bolded god and cameras
in stephen's utterance because you can
see siri just picks up on those as kind
of keywords and says churches and camera
stores it's not even topically relevant
it's just a complete failure to
recognize what he's trying to do and
then later things get even worse siri
really doesn't understand what steven is
saying and so it does the standard
escape valve which is
it searches the web for the
speech-to-text transcription of the
thing that he said in hopes that that
will be helpful a far cry from anything
like
a helpful useful human-like interaction
with language
now why is this so difficult i think
another angle on that question uh is
usefully brought to the fore with this
not this analogy that stephen levinson
offers uh so he asks us to look at this
rembrandt sketch here and just reflect
on the fact that you can make out people
and structures in the background but
really it's incredible that you can do
any of that so he says we interpret this
sketch instantly and effortlessly as a
gathering of people before a structure
probably a gateway the people are
listening to a single declaiming figure
in the center
then he says but all this is a miracle
for there is little detailed information
in the lines or shading such as there is
every line is a mere suggestion
so here's the miracle from a mere
sketchiest squiggle of lines you and i
converge to find adam bration of a
coherent scene
that is indeed a visual miracle and a
cognitive miracle and it's also a
glimpse into why computer vision is so
challenging to make the connection with
language levinson continues the problem
of utterance interpretation is not
dissimilar to this visual miracle an
utterance is not as it were of a
ridicule model or snapshot of the scene
it describes rather an utterance is just
as sketchy as the rembrandt drawing
so much of what we communicate as
speakers is left implicit and so much of
what listeners are able to extract from
our utterances is stuff that they're
able to extract only by reasoning in a
general way about the context plans and
goals world knowledge and so forth
if our utterances were actually fully
encoding in their semantics everything
we intended to communicate i think we
would have talking robots at this point
but the truth is that so much of
communication in natural language is
left up to the context in a very general
sense
and that's exactly what makes this
problem so challenging
in a way though all of this grounding
into the context and all this reasoning
if you bring it into your system it can
make things easier uh it might make some
intractable problems tractable and one
glimpse of that is just this topic of
what linguists and philosophers call
indexicality and dexicals are phrases
like i as in i am speaking that
obviously makes reference to the speaker
and that reference is going to vary
depending on who's speaking that's a
case where you can't possibly understand
this statement unless you know something
about
who's speaking which is a very simple
kind of grounding
we one shows this a similar kind of
grounding but it's more complicated so
now we have this phrase we which
probably by default is expected to
include the speaker but it needs to
include others and figuring out who else
it includes can be difficult and you
also get more challenging uses where you
say things like we as in we as the
sports team that i follow or something
like that so we have grounding plus a
whole bunch of contextual reasoning in
order to figure out what we want would
mean
i am here of course i for the speaker
that's one kind of grinding but here is
an indexical expression referring to a
location and it does that in a very
complicated way when i say i am here i
could mean my office or stanford and i
suppose all the way up to planet earth
although that's unlikely because it's
not so informative in 2021 to say i am
on planet earth
we want to go here as another use it has
weed for one kind of grounding and in
this case here if i'm pointing to a map
would be an even more complicated kind
of displaced indexable reference where
the map is doing some iconic duty for
some actual place in the world that we
are aiming to go so another kind of
complicated reasoning but again grounded
in something about the utterance context
we went to a local bar after work here
the index goal is the word local and it
just shows that indexicality can sneak
into other parts of speech local here is
going to refer to things that are
somehow in the immediate vicinity of the
location of the utterance and again in a
very complicated way
and then three days ago tomorrow and now
are temporal indexables and they just
show that the meaning of an utterance
can vary depending on when it's spoken
and all of these expressions are kind of
anchored to that time of utterance
and there are other kinds of context
dependents that really require us to
understand utterances in their full
grounded context let's start with a
simple example where are you from this
can be a vexing question when people ask
because it can often be difficult to
know what their true true goals and
intentions are with the question they
could mean
your birthplace i would say connecticut
they could mean your nationality i might
say the u.s
affiliation for me that would be
stanford and again maybe one day it will
be informative to say planet earth if
there are intergalactic meetings that
one is typically ruled out because it's
not so helpful in 2021
but for the rest of them we kind of have
to guess often about what the speaker is
asking of us in order to figure out how
to answer
here's some other examples i didn't see
any that's one particular sentence
its meaning is underspecified in the
context of the question are there typos
in my slides i didn't see any will take
on one sense
in the context are there bookstores
downtown i didn't see any will take on a
very different sense
are there cookies in the cupboard i
didn't see any yet again another kind of
sense and of course there is no end to
the number of different contexts we can
place this sentence in and each one is
likely to modulate the meaning of i
didn't see any in some complicated and
subtle way we hardly reflect on this but
it's an incredible process
so just to round this out here's an
example routine pragmatic enrichment
i've got this simple sentence in the
middle here many students met with me
yesterday it's not a very complicated
sentence cognitively or linguistically i
think we can easily understand it but
reflect for a second on just how many
hooks this utterance has into the
context we need to know what the time of
utterance is to understand yesterday and
then turn to understand the whole
sentence we need to ask how big is the
contextually restricted domain of
students here in order to figure out
whether you know how many many is
uh is it false for most students did i
avoid saying most or all because that
would be false and instead chose a
weaker form many that would be a kind of
reasoning that many listeners will
undergo what's the additional contextual
restriction is students just students in
our course students i advise students at
stanford students in the world
again the context will tell us who's the
speaker of course that's a
straightforward indexical
and then there are other kinds of
inferences that we might make based on
the restrictive modifiers that the
speaker chose
again we don't reflect on it but all
this stuff is happening kind of
effortlessly and automatically this in
levinson's terms is the merest
sketchiest squiggle of what actually
gets communicated and that is what's so
hard about so many aspects of nlu
now i want to go back into history at
least once more to terry winograd's
system sure blue because this just shows
that at the start of the field of ai and
natural language processing the focus
was entirely on these grounded
understanding problems so sure blue was
a fully grounded system that parsed the
user's input
mapped it to a logical form and
interpreted that logical form in a very
particular world and then it would try
to take some action and generate
responses it's incredible and i love
this characterization um from this
youtube clip one project did succeed
terry winograd's program shirt blue
could use english intelligently but
there was a catch the only subject you
could discuss was a micro world of
simulated blocks right this is wonderful
in the sense that it achieves the goal
of grounding but it was very far from
being scalable in any sense that would
make it practical
but here's a kind of simple dialogue
from sherloo and the thing i just want
to point out is that there is so much
implicit grounding into the context the
box is restricted to the domain and
therefore has reference of course there
isn't a unique box in the universe so
the box in the general context might be
very confusing but in the blocks world
it made sense and you can see that
person leveraging that and the computer
can understand it because it too is
grounded in this particular context and
therefore can make use of all of that
implicit information
informing its utterances and
interpreting the humans utterances and
you see that pervasively throughout
sample dialogues with assured loop it's
a compelling vision about the kinds of
things that we need to have and all of
it turns on this very rich notion of
grounding in the blocks world
finally another connection i want to
make let's just think the very best
devices in the universe as far as we
know for acquiring natural languages are
humans
what do humans do well first language
acquirers children learn language with
incredible speed that's noteworthy just
a few years
despite relatively few inputs i mean
they get a lot of language data in the
ideal situation but it's nothing
compared to what currently language
models get to see
and they use cues from contrast inherent
in the forms they hear that's a
distributional idea that we're familiar
with but also social cues and
assumptions about the speaker's goals
but i just feel like the very richness
of this picture and its multimodal
aspects
are really important guiding clues for
us
so what are the consequences of all this
for nou well as i said since human
children are the best agents in the
university learning language and they
depend on grounding it seems like our
systems ought to be grounded as well
problems that are intractable without
grounding are solvable with the right
kinds of grounding that's important to
keep in mind grounded problems can seem
hard but the other aspect of that is
that some problems might be completely
intractable unless you have some notion
of grounding indexables come to line
thinking about current day modeling deep
learning is a flexible toolkit for
reasoning about different kinds of
information in a single model you can
bring in language data image data event
video data audio data and so forth and
therefore it has led to conceptual
improvements
the ungrounded language models of today
get a lot of publicity but there are
also many exciting systems that are
fluently reasoning about images and
video and language together and i think
that's a really nice step forward into
the world of true grounding
so we should seek out and develop data
sets that include the right kind of
grounding because the central thesis
here is that that can lead to
progress by leaps and bounds
so again to round this out let me
encourage you to think about this for
final projects we're going to be working
with the stanford english colors and
context corpus there is also a chinese
version and we've explored exciting
ideas involving monolingual chinese and
english speakers as well as bilingual
models for this data set
if you want to do a little bit more in
terms of grounding slightly more
complicated context i would recommend
the one common data set
the enviro map corpus is an early task
oriented grounded corpus that could be
exciting especially if you want to do
some interesting initial steps involving
language and reinforcement learning
the cards corpus would be much more
ambitious along those same lines it's
very open-ended difficult task oriented
dialogue corpus
dealer no deal is a forward-thinking
negotiation corpus negotiation is a very
interesting kind of slightly adversarial
social grounding uh craigslist bargain
is another data set that you might use
in the context of negotiation agents
and then alfred crosstalk and room to
room are all data sets that would allow
you to combine grounded language
understanding with problems relating to
computer vision in various ways and
again that kind of
interdisciplinary connection could be
crucial to making progress on truly
grounded systems